now science correspondent thomas moore
joins me now and thomas it's uh just
been announced that new restrictions
will be introduced in wales where from
the 27th of december there'll be new
social distancing rules in workplaces
and nightclubs will be closed clearly
there's growing concern about the spread
of omicron
yes and many scientists would argue that
there need to be tighter restrictions
across the country because that's going
to be so important in buying time to
roll out the booster and but that the
government is relying on that as its
mainstay for for dealing with the
omicron variant and three-quarters of a
million people today did get their
booster but it's at the right people we
know that it's really important to give
protection against the new variant but
i've been digging in some of the detail
of
data released today by the uk health
security agency which shows that there
are almost a million people over the age
of 65 those most at risk from this
variant
who have yet to receive their booster
and these aren't vaccine refuse nicks
these are people who've already had two
doses but are waiting for the booster at
the same time there are 3.4 million that
are aged between 50 and 65 waiting for
thirds and yet there are 1.6 million
people under the age of 40 low-risk
people who have managed to get theirs
already so questions over with the jab
is being prioritized uh properly but the
chief medical officer chris whitty was
before the health select committee today
and he was saying that it's very
possible that you get this big rise in
in cases which will lead to a big rise
in hospital admissions a very sharp peak
which was going to put hospitals under
great pressure in the coming weeks but
it depends also on the severity of the
variant it's entirely possible that
people need hospital treatment for a
much shorter period and therefore they
need a bed for less less time and
clearing it for the new admissions but
he did also say that there are brighter
skies ahead but it's likely the pandemic
is going to last for the next 18 months
but each successive six months will be
better than the last and that i think is
something to cling on to